-Robert De Niro
is my guest tonight.
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I saw De Niro backstage,
and I was like,
"You're on the show.
It's good. It's good.
You're on the show."
And he said, "Keep doing that,
and I won't be."
And I go...
Robert stars in the new movie
"The Irishman"
with Al Pacino and Joe Pesci.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a little strange
to hear those three guys
in a movie called
"The Irishman." That's...
That's like a movie starring
Liam Neeson, Colin Farrell,
and Pierce Brosnan
called "The Italians."
[ Irish accent ] "You try
the lasagna now, then."
This is the third night in a row
we are coming to you live,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
But don't worry. Don't worry.
If you missed anything, we have
a White House staffer backstage
typing up a transcript, so...
That's right.
That's the big news today.
Trump released the transcript
of his phone call
with the president of Ukraine.
It started with him saying...
And Trump said,
"But enough about me."
Then later in the transcript,
there was a pretty damaging part
where Trump talks about
Biden's son.
When Trump saw that part,
he said,
"That can't be my transcript.
It looks nothing like
my handwriting."
You can tell Trump is
running out of explanations.
Today he was like,
"It's not me on the transcript.
It's Alec Baldwin."
The situation
is escalating fast.
Today it was all about
impeachment, whistle-blowers,
transcripts.
Can't we go back
to when things were simpler
and the President was just
fighting with Chrissy Teigen?
Now a lot of Democrats
have come out to show
their support for
the impeachment of Trump.
You could tell they're onboard
because Nancy Pelosi
crowd-surfed her way
into the office today.
A lot of people are calling
the transcript a smoking gun,
which explains
why today Trump said,
"Okay. Now I'm ready
for gun control."
And this is crazy.
Today Trump actually
met in person with
the president of Ukraine.
Take a look at this.
-I know that you've
never been in Ukraine.
Can you give me a word that you
will come to our great country?
-Well, I'm going to try.
[ Laughter ]
-Eric and Don Jr. heard that
and were like,
"Well, based on all of
our Little League games,
trust us, he's not showing up."
"I'm gonna try to be there
for you guys. I don't know."
After that,
Trump held a press conference
and listed all the countries
he's met with this week.
Check it out.
>> Pakistan, Poland,
New Zealand,
Singapore, Egypt,
South Korea,
United Kingdom, India.
-"And that's just one visit
to Epcot."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
This impeachment story is huge,
and the media is really racing
to keep up with it.
It's getting kind of nuts.
Look what I saw on CNN.
This is real.
There's news scrolling
on the bottom of the screen
and the top!
It got even crazier later.
Look at this video.
>> The complaint that started...
[ Laughter ]
-Ridiculous.
You can't even see.
I feel bad for Wolf Blitzer.
-Oh, come on.
-Some TV news tonight.
On NBC, there was
and all-new "Chicago Med,"
"Chicago Fire,"
and "Chicago PD".
That was followed by
"Chicago Post Office,"
"Chicago DMV,"
and "Chicago Zoo."
And, finally, Amazon announced
that you'll soon be able to get
Samuel L. Jackson to be
the voice of your Amazon Echo.
Yeah, and when they told Alexa,
she was like...
-Alex: Get that
mother [bleep] actor away
from my mother [bleep] job.
-We have a great show.